- I don't use that phrase like,
"It saved my life", gingerly
but I mean, that suicide
hotline phone call,
it saved my life.
The story actually begins prior
to me calling the hotline.
We use the word "crazy"
loosely a lot of the time
but I think the best way to describe
the feeling I was having
at the time was crazy.
I was by myself.
I was actually on my way
to pick up my daughter
at the time from daycare.
Being on the bus and feeling crazy like,
I wanted to take my clothes off,
I wanted to jump off the
bus, I wanted to harm myself.
I can't call a suicide
hotline on the bus right now
'cause that's gonna look really crazy.
So the best thing to do
would be to, I had known
that New York has like, I
forget what the number is,
that where essentially you
can have a text conversation
to help you through the process
if you feel like you're
going to harm yourself.
It was like, I'm trying to
text, I text the message.
It took like a minute to get back
and it's like, "What is your problem?"
I was like, okay, I'm gonna
text you, robot person
on the other side, what my problem is.
Okay, I don't know what
to do, I'm panicking.
I'm like, okay do I run
across the street because
at this point, I'm trying
to figure out either,
do I harm myself or do I not harm myself?
Like one or two, and I'm
like, okay well I need
to do something, so I
called the suicide hotline
and I can't remember the
exact, like how the phone call
began essentially, but
I remember the feeling
of the phone call and I
remember being affirmed
because I just felt overwhelmed.
And between work, between
life, between fatherhood,
between not really
knowing what I was doing
and in that moment, it
felt like it was going
to be easier to not be here
and to essentially try to end my life.
And to have a person kind
of listen to the stress
at the moment and say,
"It is okay, you're okay,
wow this must be really hard for you,
this situation is really difficult.
You're doing a fantastic job, though,
based on what you're telling me."
Listening without judgment, without bias,
without prejudice, that
suicide hotline phone call
saved my life and I wish I
could remember the sister's name
who I spoke to because she was
so warm, she was so loving,
she was so comforting.
She sounded like a black auntie.
Warm, the warmth was the word.
There were no identifying
questions at all.
She doesn't know my name.
She doesn't know where I'm from.
She didn't know where I was located.
The conversation was directly related
to what I was going through
at that present moment and those feelings.
She didn't ask me anything
else like, where are you,
or you know, none of that.
Part of what she was doing was just
allowing me the space really to vent.
It was less questions and more affirming.
It was just something I needed
because there's that level
of shame you feel,
essentially, when you're trying
to tell a person that you care about
that I essentially wanna harm myself
because then it's very
easy, unfortunately,
for people who do know you,
to start blaming themselves.
I think, sometimes there's a fear, right?
Like, okay, do I make this phone call?
Am I essentially going to look crazy?
Is it crazy, does it even work?
And granted, I'm very much the
person that doesn't believe
in absolutes, so not
everything works for everybody.
Sometimes maybe it's not the
hotline, maybe it's a relative,
it's a friend, it's someone
you know you can call who's
going to essentially be
able to give you that space
and that freedom and that
room to give of yourself
without concern of bias
or prejudice or judgment,
but the suicide hotline
did that for me, for sure.
It's easy to kind of
stigmatize how a person looks
who might be suffering from some level
of like a mental health disorder
or a person who may be depressed.
I don't look like the stereotypical person
who's been suffering from that.
I'm also going through
this and processing this.
I know you probably are too.
I've kind of been blessed
and fortunate enough
to be given the opportunity
to have the language
and have the space to do
that, so I feel like it's kind
of my duty to kind of share
that with other people.